We're asked to use the
distributive property
to expand this expression.
So let me get my
little scratch pad out.
So this is the same
question right over here.
So we're going to multiply 6
times this entire quantity.
So let me just rewrite
this as 6 times negative 4w
plus one half.
So we're going to
distribute the 6.
So this is going to be 6
times negative 4w times 6,
plus 6 times one
half, so this is
going to be-- let me
just write it this way--
6 times negative 4w
plus 6 times one half.
And this is going to be equal
to 6 times negative 4w is
negative 24w, and then
6 times one half is 3.
So we get negative 24w plus 3.
So let me write that down.
Negative 24w plus 3.
And let's check our answer.